a French company wins a contract in
Spain it sends over some of its
employees to carry out the contract on a
temporary basis these employees are
called posted workers in 2014 there were
almost 2 million posted workers in the
EU that's less than 1% of the total EU
workforce which is not a lot but posted
workers are highly concentrated in
certain sectors such as construction
today employers are not obliged to pay
posted workers more than the minimum
wage set by the host country this can
create wage gaps between posted and
local workers it can also result in
unfair competition between companies
it's now time to adapt EU rules to
ensure that posting takes place in fair
conditions both for workers and for
companies we need rules on equal pay and
working conditions for posted and local
workers the European Commission's goal
is to guarantee that labor mobility
across the EU works in a way that is
fair to all
you